Definitely don't make it about yourself.
A lot of people will say, "Oh, well, you're sad."
"Well, you know, it could be so much worse,"
or "Everybody deals with hard times."
It's not a choice. Nobody wants to experience these things.
Nobody wants to go through them.
Definitely say, "I'm here for you.
Please let me know how I can be a support to you in any way that I can."
Recognize that every person is going through something that you can't
necessarily understand.
If you see something on social media where someone doesn't seem to be one hundred
percent well, check in with that. Simply by saying "Hey, how's it going?"
And letting them know that you're there for them doesn't mean that you're trying to get
in their business.
I just would be happy if people listened, and were accepting, and non-judgmental,
you know. Just say, "I'm here for you. If you want to talk, talk. If you don't want to talk,
we can just sit here and eat pizza.